I'd like you to get started by looking at the structure
and the summary of the Yerger data set on your own
computer. You may want to pause the video now to give yourself
some time to load in the data set and to download it
first from the instructor notes. This Yerger data set contains over
2000 observations. For nine different
variables. The observations are for households
that buy Dannon yogurt over time. Now one thing that you
might notice is that most of the variables in here are integers.
But I want to convert one of the variables to a factor, and
that's the ID variable. We'll see how this comes in handy later
in the course. But just make sure it says factor right here
on your data set as well. If ID doesn't say factor for
the type of variable, make sure you run this command in order
to change ID to a factor variable. Once you've done all this,
I want you to create a histogram of the Yogurt prices. Copy
and paste your R code in to the R chunk on the quiz
screen that will appear here. And then write a
few sentences about what you notice. So that way
we can be consistent as we work through the
data set together. I want you to be sure to
read in the data set into the variable called
Yo. You can, of course, use other variable names.
But our auto grader will only accept answers for
programming assignments that have this data frame labeled as Yo.